[Musica]
sempre bello ritrovarsi tra pochi intimi
a parlare come dire di argomenti così
sottili e irrilevanti
allora il primo punto che vorrei provare
a trattare con voi
la questione di come noi stiamo provando
a gestire la complessità
stiamo provando a gestire un cambiamento
è un mutamento senza precedenti ci sono
state altre trasformazioni nel
susseguirsi delle civiltà umane ma mai
così profonde e radicali e stiamo
provando a gestire qualcosa che in
realtà non è gestibile lo sfondo questo
gigantesco con fraintendimento tra il
complicato e il complesso ma vorrei
partire un po da qui da questo concetto
delle false dicotomie perché di fronte a
questa trasformazione antropologica
profonda ripete radicale senza
precedenti
stiamo provando a tenere separato
qualcosa che è profondamente unito
provate a pensarlo e le o chiamate false
dicotomie alcune sono storiche ataviche
ce le portiamo dietro da sempre
naturacultura naturale artificiale
cultura tecnologia che si traducono poi
nella nei processi educativi e formativi
si traducono poi nella costruzione e
progettazione dell'architettura
complessiva dei nostri saperi
a mio avviso il vero motivo del ritardo
culturale con cui noi ci stiamo
confrontando fateci caso tra le grandi
narrazioni della civiltà e bear
tecnologica iperconnessa cioè quella che
ci racconta sempre continuamente che la
tecnologia va ad una velocità e la
cultura non riesce a starle dietro
ecco questo già a mio avviso è una
evidenza di questa premessa solamente
fuorviante ingannevole perché ci
presenta la tecnologia come un qualcosa
di neutrale come un qualcosa di
soprattutto di esterno e contesti
culturali e alla cultura
e su questo tipo di impostazione ripeto
si costruisce questo gigantesco
fraintendimento che a mio avviso è alla
base di due questioni
importanti fondamentali che sono poi
riconducibili alle sfide della
complessità dell'eyewear complessità
la prima è quella che riguarda il grande
equivoco della civiltà iper tecnologica
e iper complessa qual è questo grande
equivoco e quello che fa coincidere
l'educazione la formazione che sono un
unico sistema non entità separate la
scuola e l'università e tutte le
tematiche che hanno a che fare con
l'educazione la formazione el
aggiornamento come se fossero questioni
di natura esclusivamente tecnica con una
particolare attenzione un particolare
focus sulla questione delle competenze e
del saper fare
laddove noi sappiamo bene anche lì falsa
dicotomia il saper fare senza il sapere
non porta da nessuna parte anzi noi
abbiamo bisogno di imparare a saper
comunicare il sapere che a saper
comunicare il saper fare
sullo sfondo l'altra falsa dicotomia
conoscenze competenze
bene noi stiamo provando a governare
processi che non sono governabili
processi che di fatto ci mettono in
condizione di operare un irreversibile
salto di qualità in cui amo definirla
così la trasformazione antropologica
siamo di fronte al ribaltamento di
quella interazione complessa tra
l'evoluzione biologica e l'evoluzione
culturale fuori dal potere e dal portato
ideologico delle parole cosa intendo
dire cosa voglio dire con questa formula
intendo dire che adora in virtù delle
straordinarie scoperte scientifiche
innovazioni tecnologiche è l'evoluzione
culturale a determinare quella biologica
lo sarà sempre di più perché questa
trasformazione antropologica si basa tra
le tante questioni sul progressivo
impossessarsi da parte degli esseri
umani delle leve della propria
evoluzione e questo è un elemento
importante in una fase in cui a mio
avviso esiste poca consapevolezza anche
nell'accademia nel mondo della ricerca
scientifica delle profonde implicazioni
etiche ed epistemologiche della fase che
stiamo che stiamo vivendo a questo
aggiungeteci come appunto l'architettura
complessiva dei saperi è strutturata e
su come ancora le nostre scuole le
nostre università sono progettate
riformate barra controriforma te sulla
base di logiche di separazioni che
tendono a recludere i saperi le
competenze le discipline e tendono a non
farli dialogare anche qui
altra falsa dicotomia contrapporre la
specializzazione dei saperi
all'interdisciplinarità i saperi non
possono che specializzarsi e sempre di
più si specializzeranno il problema e
non averli fatti dialogare ecco perché
la falsa dicotomia e non averli fatti
dialogare ha avuto delle profonde
ripercussioni non soltanto a livello
della difficoltà poi di abitare questa
complessità ma ha avuto delle
ripercussioni importanti anche perché
proprio dentro le istituzioni educative
e formative sono stati reclusi anche le
esperienze e vissuti da qui l'urgenza di
ripensare lo spazio relazionale
educativo e comunicativo dentro le
istituzioni educative e formative
io credo che questa sia la sfida delle
sfide ancora una volta che su questo
ripeto due parole sul quello che ho
chiamato il gigantesco fraintendimento
tra complicato e complesso il complicato
quando parliamo di sistemi complicati
parliamo di sistemi artificiali e
meccanici parliamo del mondo degli
oggetti e delle cose che è governato da
forze da variabili in cui la presenza
dell'osservatore e la sofisticazione di
strumenti e importante però sono sistemi
sempre insieme di parti governati da
interazioni che si muovono come insieme
ma di fatto sono sistemi in cui noi come
dire anche dal punto vista del valore
conoscitivo della valenza conoscitiva
possiamo scomporle isolarne le parti
osservarle e sulla base appunto della
individuazione queste
relazioni lineare pensate a un orologio
al motore di un aereo a un computer
possiamo come dire far sì che questi
sistemi siano prevedibili e gestibili
proprio perché rispondenti a relazioni
lineari
il complesso i sistemi complessi sono i
sistemi umani sociali relazionali con
qualche sfumatura biologica dovrei dire
qualcosa sul caos sul caos
deterministico che fa un po sconquassa
un po anche questo schema però passate i
sistemi complessi dicevo sono con gli
umani sociali relazionali biologici non
rispondono a relazioni lineare la
relazione è sempre sistemica non si può
isolare la parte per risolvere il
problema
pensate anche alle illusioni della
civiltà iper tecnologica iperconnessa e
anche di certa politica di trovare
soluzioni semplici a problemi complessi
e dietro le soluzioni semplici c'è
ancora una volta il ricorso ad approcci
del sano riduzionisti cioè deterministi
c'è ancora una volta la tentazione
l'illusione di poter gestire qualcosa
che non è gestibile
la complessità non si può gestire non è
un problema di parole possiamo provare a
governarla
possiamo provare ad abitarla e qui il
discorso della sfida educativa perché
sennò siamo solo nel peso delle parole
delle parole che hanno fascino abitare
la complessità oli per complessità
ci sono dei motivi dietro queste
definizioni significa in primo luogo
mettere mano in maniera radicale
all'educazione e alla formazione
i processi educativi e formativi non
possono sostanziarsi semplicemente in un
adeguamento in un esterne un'estensione
di un'educazione tradizionale al
cambiamento tecnologico
c'è un aspetto centrale in tutto questo
bisogna lavorare per creare e diffondere
una cultura dell'errore ma queste sono
ancora una volta le grandi illusioni
della civiltà iper tecnologici
quali sono diciamole l'illusione del
controllo tema che l'essere umano si
porta dietro da sempre
l'illusione della razionalità
l'illusione della prevedibilità la
prevedibilità dei sistemi e soprattutto
l'illusione questo secondo me è molto
attuale rispetto alla civiltà iper
tecnologica dell'automazione l'illusione
di poter espellere
l'errore è l'imprevedibilità dalle
nostre vite dai sistemi sociali dalle
organizzazioni questa è l'illusione
peggiore
e se ci riflettete eliminare espellere
l'errore e l'imprevedibilità mette in
discussione il nostro stesso modo di
esseri umani
l'errore l'imprevedibilità non solo sono
le basi su cui si fonda la conoscenza
scientifica e la ricerca l'errore è
l'imprevedibilità sono i fattori che ci
rendono umani sono i fattori che ci
rendono esseri umani
aggiungo sono i fattori che ci rendono
esseri umani liberi non sono preoccupato
in un momento in cui le scoperte
scientifiche alle innovazioni
tecnologiche fanno saltare qualunque
tipo di confine tra naturale e
l'artificiale non mi preoccupa il fatto
che le macchine o rio bo possano
somigliare agli esseri umani
anzi questo agevolerà questa interazione
complessa da cui non potrà che scaturire
una sintesi complessa
mi preoccupa molto di più l'idea
dell'aspirazione che gli esseri umani
intendono assomigliare alle macchine
potenziando in maniera infinita alle
proprie capacità di calcolo le proprie
capacità di analisi ma soprattutto
ancora una volta espellendo il discorso
dell'errore dell'imprevedibilità
guardate come anche i sistemi di
intelligenza artificiale non si tratta
di essere pro o contro l'automazione se
voi immaginate la società noi col nostro
spazio sistemico relazionale e
comunicativo come un immenso sistema
nervoso
i sistemi di intelligenza artificiale
vanno a sostituire con gli spazi
marginalizzando la presenza dell'umano
e questa marginalizzazione
inevitabilmente anche una
marginalizzazione dello spazio di
responsabilità e qui torniamo alla
questione del complicato complesso ecco
se non vogliamo che resti uno slogan
si tratta di recuperare le dimensioni
complesse della complessità educativa
significa riportare le emozioni dentro i
processi educativi significa andare a
demistificare ancora una volta quella
falsa dicotomia che oppone la
razionalità e alle emozioni le decisioni
razionali hanno sempre una base emotiva
significa come dicevamo prima costruire
una cultura dell'errore dolore non è
qualcosa che va come dire certo dobbiamo
tentare di non commettere errori ma
l'errore è la base della conoscenza e
alla base del nostro progredire e ancora
una volta e qui chiudo
c'è un'altra dimensione ci sarebbero
tante il tema dell'empatia visto che
abbiamo il problema del ripensare la
democrazia il nostro abitare insieme c'è
un altro punto a cui tengo molto
l'idea di educare alla libertà come
avrebbe detto qualcuno e alla
responsabilità
là dove però le dobbiamo ripensare in
una chiave che è relazionale libertà e
responsabilità presuppongono in noi non
li ho
a questo punto di vista grazie
[Applauso]